c'est un immeuble discret à quelques
minutes du centre-ville une résidence
bien entretenu doté d'une piscine ici 35
appartements seront bientôt à vendre les
locataires le savent
certains se verraient bien propriétaire
je trouve que c'est bien parce que c'est
déjà une bonne résidence on a une
piscine on a tout est là pas une bonne
chose que c'est intéressant
vous seriez prête à franchir le pas en
fait oui cette locataire vite ici depuis
14 ans dans 1 70 mètre carré elle sera
prioritaire si elle achète dans la
résidence ci se vendent à peu près 160
milles donc ça moi il y aurait fallu que
j'emprunte sur trois générations ça non
voilà tandis que là je pense que flash
est même certain que je pourrais la clé
cent dix mille euros au lieu de 160
mille un prix 30% en dessous du prix du
marché
les petites annonces on voit par exemple
un appartement à besançon 66 m² en
l'occurrence la selle quartier
échapperait qu'on vend à 100 mille euros
chez ce bailleur social
les appartements sont vendus après
rénovation de quoi éviter les surprises
on s'attache systématiquement au delà du
fait que c'est aussi une obligation
réglementaire à vendre des appartements
habitable et qu'ils soient dans une
situation pérenne
quand j'entends situation pérenne c'est
que ça nous permettent pas à des clients
d'avoir de gros investissements à faire
au moins pendant les dix ans qui suivent
leur acquisition
l'accès à la propriété tous n'aurais-je
pas au pied des immeubles les plus âgées
voient une menace que deviendront-ils si
on vend leur appartement
on m'a déjà mis à la porte une fois me
mettrais une deuxième fois non si c'est
ça néolia à 84 ans ça m'intéresse pas je
vais pas amendée tpourquoi pour payer un
corner
certains élus vont plus loin vendre
c'est diminuer le parc locatif au moment
où la demande explose
il faut qu'on arrête de vendre de raser
un certain nombre de logements publics
on sait qu'aujourd'hui la dépense
première d'un ménage c'est le logement
avec tout ce que ça peut comporter au
tour et donc on n'a pas intérêt à
laisser partir ce type de logements en
moyenne 14 % des locataires achètent
leur logement social les charges de
copropriété ont font réfléchir plus d'un